You are watching ColdFusion TV
Hi. welcome to another ColdFusion video. as most of you know Tesla
Just unveiled two electric semi-trucks and a new high-performance roadster in this video,
I'll give my thoughts and commentary on the event and what this means for Tesla, and the industry as a whole first
Let's briefly take a look at the trucks
TRUCKING is actually a bigger industry than you might imagine taking the United States as an example the trucking industry
Employs over 7 million people per year and 80 percent of all cargo in America is still transported by trucks
That's four times as much as air pipeline rail and sea combined
With this in mind you can easily see how
Logistics companies would be very interested in an electric truck that performs better and is much cheaper to run then it's diesel counterpart
Tesla shifted into high gear
Unveiling its new all-electric semi-truck joining us right now analysts at arc invest it's hasha kini Tosha. Good to see you good
Thanks so much for joining us now at arc. You cover autonomous cars and innovative materials. What did you think of the big reveal?
Well Maria it confirmed
What we had thought which is that an EV semi is going to be cheaper than a diesel semi.
And by the way that truck is semi autonomous
Today when that turns fully autonomous we think the cost per ton-mile could be reduced by 75%
From today's rates, that's gonna be cheaper than rail
It's gonna drive more goods over trucks, and it's gonna completely transform logistics as we know it Wow
The electric trucks will do 0 to 100 kilometers now or 60 miles an hour in five seconds
versus 15 seconds for the average truck in a worst-case scenario with a max gross vehicle weight of 80,000 pounds or about
36 tons the truck will be able to get 500 miles of range an
Electric truck is inherently easier to drive because there's no gears, but meanwhile. It's not uncommon for normal trucks to have over 16 gears
Tesla claims that 30 minutes of charge will get you 400 miles and
For reference to fill the tank of a normal truck takes about 15 minutes
So either way this makes sense if you've been driving a long time and just need a break
Auto pilot will be standard so if you have a medical emergency while driving the truck will keep to its lane
Gradually stop, and if it doesn't hear a response from you it even calls an ambulance
The truck is also claimed to be a lot safer one of the reasons is due to a lower center of gravity from the weight
Of the battery packs making rollovers very unlikely
The risk of the truck jackknifing has also been said to be virtually eliminated due to independent torque vectoring on each wheel
the company is offering a 1 million mile guarantee on each of these vehicles, so
Although that's all pretty cool, and potentially revolutionary the main story was the Tesla Roadster 2.0
the original roadster was the car that started Tesla back in 2008 The Electric Forest had its share of
obituaries over the years
but the new American car company Tesla is determined to prove that the concept is a workable one the
Manufacturer has just launched the Tesla Roadster an electric car that looks good and can hold its own in the performance arena so far
Tesla is off to a promising start
Tesla has pre-sold about 900 cars
And it plans to build and sell over 3,000 more in 2009 and 2010 and in
2017 it was finally time for a refresh the new updated model is an absolute beast
So as many of you know it can do 0 to 100 kilometres an hour or 60 miles an hour in 1.9 seconds
And it's the first production car in the world to break the two-second barrier
And it can do zero to 160 kilometres an hour or a hundred miles an hour in 4.2 seconds
It's said to also produce 10 kilonewton meters of torque at the wheels
At the recent presentation musk didn't say the top speed, but did say that it was above 250 miles an hour or 400 kilometers now
by comparison the Agera RS by Sweden's Koenisseg currently holds the world record at
277.9 miles an hour or about
445 kilometers an hour
The crowd was still getting over the top speed figures when musk announced that the roadster
had a 200 kilowatt hour battery which were provided
620 miles of range or over a thousand kilometers for comparison the P 100 D has about 420 miles of range I
Think the range will be key to converting or at least convincing those that are critical of electric cars
That this is no longer a gimmick and also for all of this. It's important to note that
This is the base model the slowest option of this new Tesla Roadster
So the question has to be asked is this actually feasible, or is this pie in the sky
Or the website Jalopnik spoke word Carnegie Mellon's venkat Viswanathan mechanical engineering assistant professor
He focuses on next-generation battery technology. He remarked that the 1.9. Second figure actually seems reasonable
he added that a 200 kilowatt hour battery pack can easily go 600 miles an
interesting point of note is he estimates that the battery weight alone will be 833 kilograms or
1,800 pounds as
It turns out
It's actually the grip on the tires and the management of getting the power down from the motors to the actual wheels that will be
the main bottlenecks in this vehicle
But Tesla has actually had a lot of experience with the P 100 D on that front
So it seems reasonable that they could get that done
The thing that stood out to me is that this car is breaking all the records
It looks like Tesla is doing this to make a solid point this vehicle was meant to be a statement a kind of watershed
Moment to tell people that this is the direction that cars going to take
No one can argue with it if it's faster quicker and more value for money than most supercars that are out there
But that is if the production model has the same numbers that are listed for the prototype figures
Speaking of other supercars. He is a fun list of how the Roadster 2.0. Stacks up against the petrel competition
Nissen gt-r Nismo version 0 to 60 in 2.7 seconds costing you
175,000 McLaren p1 GTR 0 to 60 2.4 seconds at a cost of 3.6 million dollars
lamborghini aventador sv 0 to 60 2.4 seconds again cost four hundred ninety three thousand bugatti chiron
zero to sixty two point three seconds cost
2.6 million
Now this next one is interesting the Dodge Challenger SRT demon coming out next year
0 to 60 in 2.3 seconds cost eighty four thousand dollars, so that's actually great value for money
next up the Porsche 918 Spyder zero to sixty in two point two seconds cost eight hundred forty five thousand and
Then of course the new Tesla Roadster zero to sixteen one point nine seconds cost two hundred thousand
So the question must be asked are there any cars that can actually do zero to sixty in under two seconds right now
The answer is yes, but they're all f1 cars dragsters or rally cars
But surprisingly the acceleration of f1 cars average from about 2.1 seconds 2.7 seconds
for fun
Nasa's saturn v. Rocket can do 0 to 60 in 1.5 seconds
But if you learnt the ultimate a top fuel dragster can do that in 0.8
seconds
it accelerates so
Quickly that the car is already traveling at 60 miles an hour by the time the rear tires have crossed the start line
You've got to keep in mind that these drag cars can't even turn properly and need a parachute to even slow down
This isn't to mention that that they can only see one person and consume over half a standard tank of fuel per run
So all in all 1.9
Seconds by Tesla in a production car isn't bad at all and if the company can get this into production by 2020 as planned
The world has no choice, but to realize that they're looking at the future
But all of that being said it's not all roses for Tesla. There's a wider context at play that I should talk about
Some analysts were saying that this new roadster may have been a way to shift
Investor attention away from the model 3 production issues and reignite some excitement in the company
And I got to say that when I was watching the announcement
I hadn't sensed - such excitement and elation from a crowd since the Apple keynotes of old
I'm not so sure if the sole purpose of the Roadster was to shift attention away from the model 3
But I can certainly see the announcement being rushed forward to partly achieve that so anyway
What production issues am I talking about with the model 3?
most of you know the model 3 was supposed to be the electric car that was for the masses
When it was launched back in July the company was anticipating a production rate of
20,000 cars per month by the end of December in the last quarter though Tesla only produced
260 model threes earlier in November
Tesla pushed back its target volume production on the model 3 by about 3 months to fix production bottlenecks
It's no secret that the fate of
Tesla largely hangs on the success of the model 3 so it's important that they get this right and with vehicles like the electric semi
Truck and the new roadster in the pipeline. I really do want Tesla to succeed so that these vehicles come to fruition
It would be a lot easier to sit and criticize about how the company is missing deadlines
But I think it's worth appreciating the magnitude of what the company is actually trying to do within the auto industry
It's not easy for such a small and brand-new company, so hopefully the production issues get sorted out and the rest flows smoothly from there
So anyway, what do you guys think what's your views on the Tesla truck and the new roadster?
Let me know your thoughts in the comments section below
Anyway, thanks for watching. I know if being away for a little while I've actually been pretty sick
I'm feeling better now
But I recently just got my house broken into so that was another thing to add to what was going on
But everything should be on track after this week, anyway. Thanks for watching
I'll see you guys soon for the next video this has been togo go you've been watching cold fusion cheers guys
Have a good one
Cold Fusion, It's new thinking.